en effet c'est une affaire qui fait
penser à l' affaire du sang contaminé
mais elle n'est toutefois pas de même
nature parce que jusqu'à 88 jusqu'à
l'utilisation des hormones de synthèse
qui elle je le rappelle ne sont pas
dangereuses jusqu'en 88 donc il n'y
avait pas d'alternative
les traitements se faisait forcément
avec des hormones naturelles il semble
cependant qu'il y avait un risque qu'on
le connaissait et que toutes les
précautions n'est pas été prises
florence bukiya aujourd'hui le
traitement pour les enfants atteints de
nanisme et fiable on utilise l'hormone
de croissance de synthèse créées par
génie génétique
mais jusqu'en 1988 france hypophyse
extrayait et diffuser une hormone de
croissance naturelle extraite de
l'hypophyse collectées sur les cerveaux
de cadavres certains enfants ainsi
traités ont été du même coup condamné à
mort contaminées par la maladie de
creutzfeldt jacob qui entraîne une
dégénérescence du cerveau
dès 1980 le professeur luc montagnier
avait rappelé à france hypophyse que des
précautions importantes devaient être
prises pour éviter toute contamination
virologiques
d'après un rapport de l'igas
l'inspection générale des affaires
sociales remis au ministère de la santé
l'an dernier
ces précautions ont été manifestement
insuffisante
aujourd'hui le président de france
hypophyse l'un des médecins mise en
examen dans cette affaire se défend le
rapport de l'igas parle en effet d'un
manque de précautions dans la collecte
je crois sincèrement que c'est une fille
très partiels les choses il semble que
les inspecteurs se soit occupé
essentiellement de
ou uniquement de la région parisienne
essentiellement de quelques hôpitaux
dont ils ont interrogé les personnels où
il entre avec sa manette pas je pense
que si leur enquête avait pu être plus
large paris et abordez vous ces deux
grandes villes provence il aurait pu
avoir des sons de cloche différents en
1985 après plusieurs décès les
etats-unis et d'autres pays suspendre
tout traitement à l'hormone de
croissance
mais france hypophyse elle est autorisée
par la direction de la pharmacie et du
médicament a continué son action
seul bémol la technique de purification
de l'eau doit être améliorée chose faite
mais toujours selon l'igas les lots
d'hormones non purifier n'aurait jamais
été retirés de la circulation